the border the boundary that is
incredibly tough to smuggle a monkey
across I am told President Trump has
famously made securing the border a key
priority for his administration most
notably through his border wall
something which as we pointed out before
he himself inadvertently found a floor
in on the campaign trail there's no
ladder going over there if they ever get
up there they're in trouble because
there's no way to get down maybe a rub
yeah yep maybe a rug I know that sounds
stupid but to be fair you haven't heard
phase six of Donald Trump's border
security plan go get me all the rugs and
while that wall idea has received a lot
of coverage it is by no means Trump's
only border plan one of his more benign
sounding but potentially no less
dangerous ideas concerned the Border
Patrol and first let's be clear about
who they are they are part of Customs
and Border Protection they are not ice
who you may know from immigration rates
they're also not customs officers who
you'll see at airports and border
crossings nor are they the borders
patrol a group of vigilantes who defend
abandoned borders bookstores from
raccoons know the border patrol are the
people in green uniforms who literally
patrol the boundaries of our country
there are around 20,000 of them but
Trump in an executive order has called
for them to add 5,000 more to tackle the
many problems that he sees on our
southern border let's stop the drugs and
a crime from pouring into our country
you can certainly have terrorists you
can certainly have Islamic terrorists
you can have anything coming across the
border we're going to have a strong
strong strong border that people are
going to respect and the drugs are not
going to be flowing across like gravy
now that right there is what happens
when Donald Trump starts a sentence
feelings and a phobic and ends it
feeling hungry
need to stop Mexicans coming in like hot
fudge sundaes coming into my tummy three
scoops whipped cream no cherry because I
don't do fruit but for the record Border
Patrol agents do a lot more than just
fights drugs crime and gravy in recent
years the number of Mexicans apprehended
crossing the border has dramatically
dropped and has now been surpassed by
the sharp rise in migrants fleeing
violence in Central America for whom
there is a legal process to seek asylum
here meaning that agencies days can
frequently include moments like this
the botch a family take their first
tentative steps into the United States
of America within seconds the Border
Patrol err on them there's no chase no
tension they expected to be caught close
in as we film another two figures emerge
a mother and her daughter they're given
blankets to protect them from the cold
that's kind of not what people expect
when they think of the border in the in
a Venn diagram of hardened drug dealers
and people who need blankets that middle
section is pretty much just Linus I'm
sorry he is not a drug dealer the messy
hair the stripy shirt for thumb-sucking
he sells ecstasy at raves and he's high
on his own supply all the time there is
no Great Pumpkin he's a junkie someone
intervenes
but when the truth is it is moments like
that there that show how difficult the
job of a Border Patrol agent can be
because in that moment they are
delivering aid and processing migrants
but later that same day they may be
chasing down drug traffickers so it's a
mixture between humanitarian work and
law enforcement and not everyone can do
it and that is what makes Transplant to
expand the Border Patrol by 25% so
concerning because if you hire agents
quickly and badly it can actually leave
us much less safe and have devastating
consequences and the reason we know this
is because we have been down this road
before so tonight I would like to talk
to you about the last Border Patrol
hiring search because it wasn't that
long ago after the so-called bungling of
intelligence leading up to 9/11
President George W Bush is determined to
shore things up at the borders as part
of that mandate the Border Patrol
expanded from 10,000 agents to 20,000
it's true the late 2000 saw a surge in
Border Patrol agents that was matched
only by the surge in the number of
reality shows about people making cakes
there are so many of those you don't
even know which one of them I made up it
was by the way cake which I
guarantee you are we in production
sometime next week now now to meet the
surges ambitious targets recruitment was
aggressive and the government advertised
everywhere even at one point doing this
the Border Patrol spent eight point four
million dollars sponsoring this car
getting a detailed and staffing
recruiting booth that is obviously true
they sponsored a NASCAR team winning the
Border Patrol is such fine company as
other actual NASCAR sponsors depends
underwear and boudreaux's Butt Paste a
product for I assume people who want
their butt pasted closed and looked at
that wasn't all they also ran strictly
produce TV ads like this as a mobile law
enforcement arm of the Department of
Homeland Security it is the job of the
Border Patrol to prevent terrorists and
terrorist weapons and all those who
to do us harm from entering the United
States the Border Patrol
we protect America are you up to the
challenge yeah have to admit they make
that job look very exciting although in
fairness anything said in that tone of
voice would be exciting
here is my curtain I named him Bootsy
don't we on the rug Bootsy I'm not sure
he likes me as much as I like there but
the truth of their job is that most
agents work alone patrolling vast swaths
of desert and while some things feature
bursts of action others can involve
absolutely nothing which can be
challenging in and of itself one of the
larger problems is boredom it doesn't
mean that it's never dangerous there are
bandits out there there are drug
organizations out there what they're not
really getting is preparation for the
boring non risky reality of almost all
of their career exactly all of them is a
significant part of life as a Border
Patrol agent and they should probably
train for it for every hour they spend
in target practice they should probably
spend ten hours watching Mozart in the
jungle
are you funny am I supposed to care
about you who's that woman with the oboe
I'm confused and I'm also bored but but
the big problem was that as they doubled
in size meeting and maintaining their
hiring quotas meant that they're
screening process wasn't always as
strong as it could have been it was only
late in the surge that the CBP started
giving applicants polygraph tests
something that most other federal law
enforcement agencies do and to listen to
James Tom Scheck who headed internal
affairs for CBP through most of the
surge their findings indicated they
probably should have done that sooner
the shocking discovery we found was that
more than half of the persons who had
cleared bats on investigations failed
the polygraph examination the vast
majority of them providing detailed
descriptions of the criminal activity
they
had been involved in now just think
about that over half of CBP's applicants
who had cleared the highest level of
background check were found unsuitable
for service and some of what they
confessed who was absolutely incredible
one applicant admitted to smoking
marijuana 20,000 times in a 10-year
period
kudos to that individual while while
another stated he had no independent
recollection of the events that resulted
in a blood doused kitchen and was
uncertain if you committed any crime
during his three-hour blackout which I'm
going to go ahead and say yes you did
commit a crime oh it's a very least you
really up a souffle I mean you
that thing up bad and the
problems didn't stop once the new agents
were hired because the training was also
significantly cut back and that caused
real issues as one-china revealed while
for some reason being disguised as an
asthmatic scarecrow
we are disguising the face and voice of
this veteran agent and training
instructor because of fears of
retaliation
we went from a 20 recourse to adobe
course so the standards were lowered
well they say the standards weren't
lowered but they were what is happening
there he sounds like Jesse Ventura after
swallowing one of those novelty Cowboys
noisemakers I look I know that it is
really hard to pay attention to what
robot neil young is saying there but it
is genuinely worth listening to where
they cut corners the source told us
Spanish language classes and physical
training were cut back the person was so
out of shape I actually had to treat the
trainee and the bad guy got away pretty
much everybody gets through the Academy
they cut back on Spanish and physical
training so the new standards effective
agent ability to talk to the people they
caught and their ability to catch the
people they wanted to talk to which
seemed like pretty essential facets of
their job it's like at the training
program at SeaWorld left out putting on
a wetsuit and systematically driving
carnivorous whales insane that's the
whole job there
take them away you're left with nothing
else and consequently as the ranks grew
corruption and excessive force
skyrocketed and misconduct became such a
problem that at one point the Border
Patrol felt it needed to issue a memo
about the fact their agents were
averaging two alcohol-related arrests
per week and some agents off-duty
run-ins with the law were even more
spectacular tonight two Border Patrol
agents are on leave after a woman says
they put on a lewd show during sex SLA
performing a sex act right in front of
children the accusations don't stop
there the couple is suspected of being
drunk and violent Wow now now I should
tell you one agent was found guilty of
assaulting the woman who complained but
both denied for anything sexual was
happening and they were found not guilty
of the sex act presumably because they
were at circus today where everything
looks like a sex act I'll show you this
is a sex act this is a sex act this is a
worldly difficult sex act that is a
birdperson sex act and I have absolutely
no idea what's happening there but I
think it's the thing that Steve banning
is supposed to be good at things got
more furious than that
since 2005 77 agents were arrested or
indicted for corruption and if you think
about it Border Patrol agents are
particularly attractive to drug
traffickers remember they often work on
their own patrolling the border which as
one journalist points out is a pretty
potent recipe for trouble one Border
Patrol agent can undo an incredible
amount of good that all the other Border
Patrol agents do one Border Patrol agent
can wave in tons of drugs and you know I
literally absolutely literally yeah this
is one of the only cases where someone
saying a ton of drugs actually means a
literal ton of drugs no Kevin you did
not do a ton of drugs you took a
benadryl you're made out with a goldfish
and you're passed out with your head in
the dishwasher pull your life together
and let me give you just a taste of the
kind of spectacular corruption involved
take agent ho el Luna who it turned out
had a brother in the Gulf cocktail and
who was convicted of engaging in
organized crime with some pretty
striking evidence emerging during a
house search we end up finding a safe at
Black safe
we found eighty nine thousand dollars in
cash Oh el lunes commemorative border
patrol badge kilo and a half of cocaine
methamphetamine a gun that's tied
directly to the Gulf Cartel it says Gulf
Cartel on it hard to explain that away
it's hard to explain why your Border
Patrol bag is in a safe with cocaine
money and a cartel pistol yeah that is
really hard to explain I mean the best I
can do is my badge had a drug problem
that it couldn't bear to tell me about
so finally it decided to shoot itself
with a gun that we found on a case
planning to die surrounded by its money
because its views on death resembled
those of ancient Egyptians but even then
we are talking about a sentient police
badge with an interested in Egyptology
so you're already banking on a pretty
large suspension of disbelief there oh
and you should know Luna was hired
during the last recruitment surge and
CVP will tell you what they told us that
while some ages did disgrace the badge
with corruption the vast majority did
not although it is worth knowing that
Tom check the internal affairs guy
believes the problem is much bigger than
they imply mr. Luna is not one bad apple
he is part of a rate of corruption that
exceeded that of any other US federal
law enforcement agency okay so it's less
one bad apple than oh my god that is a
lot of bad apples which by the way
should really be the marketing theme for
Red Delicious apples
Red Delicious apples well at least we
got the red part right
and it gets even worse because remember
these agents have guns and some have
made very bad decisions and you may have
seen coverage of some of the tragic
incidents in a string of shootings by
the Border Patrol that have stirred up
emotions at the border there's one case
in particular that has become a rallying
cry for justice a shooting of a 16 year
old boy named Jose Antonio a la natural
idiot
they say their agents were threatened by
somebody throwing rocks on this side of
the fence but standing here the first
thing you ask yourself is could a 16
year old boy really threaten somebody
standing on top of what's at least a 20
foot cliff and on the other side of that
fence I mean yeah that does seem pretty
unlikely and to explain what I tune in
next week when our main story will be
gravity arch-nemesis to the concept of
up now so you know that case is still in
the court and agents can sometimes feel
threatened by rock throwers but it is
worth pointing out that a report which
looked at 25 cases where Border Patrol
agents shot people who thrown rocks
concluded that's too many cases do not
appear to meet the test of objective
reasonableness with regard to the use of
deadly force which I believe is kind of
law enforcement legalese for holy
you shot some people you should not have
shot that main thing don't do
that as much when there is one more
thing about the agent in that fence
shooting that will not surprise you he
was one of those persons hired by the
Border Patrol during the surge of course
he was and yet despite all of these
warning signs we're about to embark upon
another ambitious Border Patrol hiring
surge and CBP will tell you not to worry
about that but in recent years they've
improved hiring and made reforms for
instance they slightly increased
transparency and given agents more
non-lethal weapons like pepper spray
guns as well as rewriting their use of
force rulebook - and I quote prohibits
the shooting of suspects fleeing the
scene who do not pose a threat to
themselves or others and look that is
great although it does seem to be one of
those rules that you shouldn't have had
to write down if you went to a zoo and
there were a giant song that said please
don't finger the armadillo
you have wonder what the had
happened before that sign went up but
the problem is many other reforms have
not been made and it is hard to believe
that they will be now that president
gravy drugs is in charge in fact
worryingly there has already been taught
that hiring standards might drop again
with suggestions like a shorter
polygraph or removing parts of the
entrance exam and most frustratingly of
all there may be no reason for us to
take this risk because a report from the
inspector general for homeland security
questions whether we even need 5,000
more Border Patrol agents and yet Trump
seems determined to do this anyway who
knows why there is a fairly good chance
he only said 5,000 because someone told
him five gazillion is not a real number
and not whatever your feelings about the
laws the Border Patrol have been given
to enforce and I have plenty of feelings
on that you do want the best possible
people enforcing them because if you
don't as we have seen bad things happen
this is a story about the danger of not
learning from your mistakes and for the
sake of absolutely everybody people on
both sides of the border and the good
Border Patrol agents just trying to do a
difficult job well if we are going to
hire all these new people the very least
we can do is be more careful this time
around and one tiny step would be to
have recruitment ads that show potential
agents what the job is really like the
Border Patrol protect America and we're
hiring again but this time we're going
to do it right sort of exciting
heart-pounding adventure maybe go
skydiving or try parkour or do whatever
the this is
but the Border Patrol may not be for you
because a lot of the time the job looks
less like this and more like this
that's right just you the desert and
nothing for miles around this could be
your lunch break this is a job that can
combine hours of boredom with sudden
bursts of action oh yeah I got people
moving I need backup that action it
definitely can't involve people entering
illegally or drug smugglers but a
surprising amount of the time it
involves desperate migrants for whom
you're the first point of contact it is
system ill-equipped to cater to their
needs okay these guys yeah I don't
yes this job is not for everyone and
that's why this time we're not
advertising with NASCAR instead we're
recruiting with this sweet-ass Honda
Odyssey a practical car for reasonable
methodical people please make sure you
read the entirety of its nuanced
text before making any decisions in some
of its in Spanish because it would be
really useful if you can speak that but
just to be clear if you want to it
Cirque de Soleil this is not the job for
you and we will find out last question
have you ever and I mean ever considered
having sexual relations and a
performance of exotically dressed
Canadian acrobats
no the point is if you're kind
physically fit impervious to bribery or
boredom and you want to serve your
country by enforcing a controversial and
ever-changing set of policies in the
most humane way possible then give us a
call the Border Patrol we're hiring wish
us luck with that
circus need not apply
[Applause]